Now, in our callback, we drill down to get the GetUserData function. This will
actually give us a pointer to the entity that created these physics bodies that
are touching. Now from here, we start down a new magical rabbit hole. For each
of the objects that are touching, we need to signal, that a collision has
occurred to it. We do this by calling a new function, called onTouch, and
passing it in the other physics body that it's touching. So you can see that
entity A gets an onTouch function called, passing in body B, and entity B gets
an on touch function called passing in bodyA. This set up allows each
individual entity to respond to collisions in their own way. So for instance,
the onTouch of that for missile, would remove five health from the player it'
colliding with. Or if it's just hitting a wall, it may just decide to
self-destruct. But we haven't written this onTouch function yet. And in order
to do that, we need to hop all the way back to entity.js and add an onTouch
function. That allows other units to overload this function with custom logic
later. It's probably worth pointing out that you should be doing a whole series
of data checking to ensure that the information given to the post cell function
is valid. So for example, whether or not body A and body B are valid objects or
simply null. And whether or not the points of proper entity types and have
onTouch functions. Now we'll let you graffle through all of these issues in the
future. But we figured, that we let you get a glimpse at the madness behind the
mask. So, that means that anyone who defines a physics body should define an
onTouch function.